the jurogan experience
we are going to invent
forms of weapons
using the artificial intelligence way
before
we invent something that is capable of
the type of intelligence you're talking
about i think you're right and the
opportunities
and the opportunities to destroy
ourselves are going to be so multiple
because the world is getting so much
more complicated all the time yeah right
the number of things that can go wrong
is much bigger than in the past right 5
000 years ago there was no technology
that could have destroyed the planet
now there is
right
right and that is going to continue the
our ability to destroy the planet is
only going to get greater it's going to
take a smaller mistake to destroy the
planet
as technology gets more sophisticated so
you feel it's just human nature that if
we have control of artificial
intelligence the first thing it's going
to do is devise weapons of
no no no we are going to devise the
weapons using artificial intelligence
before there is any overarching
artificial intelligence that could take
care of us do you see what i'm saying so
you're saying the kind of artificial
intelligence that's already available
not like general artificial intelligence
which is what they think of as like a
sentient being yeah yeah yeah i mean
like stuff that we can do to like
youtube
or whatever i don't think we disagree so
you're saying that this artificial
intelligence that's in place right now
that they already use for a lot of
things yes is going to be used and make
weapons it's going to be
overwhelming we're going to use them and
we're going to use them on each other
we're going to blow each other up yes
and if we don't
artificial general intelligence is what
i'm talking about oh if we don't destroy
ourselves i'm just
you're right we've dropped bomb i mean
whenever talks about anybody talks about
anything that anyone's done anywhere in
the world when they talk about horrific
things i always say dude hiroshima and
nagasaki that is insane yeah that was a
completely untargeted city
in the sense that like there's not like
there's an army there and they're
shooting at us
no they just nuked cities
the the kind of death and destruction
that must have happened on those days to
be a person who's an innocent person
living on this regime in this city and
know that the consequences for something
that you've done nothing to all you've
done is live your life all you've done
is work in a market all you've done is
do whatever you've been a farmer and
then your entire
world is obliterated instantaneously
by an atom bomb for the first time in
human history and it's happening in your
[ __ ] city yeah well you know what in
terms of the the bombings hiroshima and
nagasaki weren't really that big a deal
in comparison to the fire bombing in
contempt comparison to the fire bomb is
in comparison to what the germans were
doing in the soviet union i understand
but there's a thing about the
instantaneous nature of those bombs that
was uniquely terrifying which is why we
haven't used them yes agreed do you have
a fear that putin would use one a
nuclear weapon yes
uh so when i was on question time
uh that program of francis do they ask
me this question
and they said if pushed would he use
them now my understanding of the word
pushed is if he feels that his life is
in danger
that's what i mean by post right i think
in that situation
he would
he would use them
however that does not mean that they
would end up being used
he may press the button
but the signal might not get to the
destination
do you see what i'm saying yes there is
a team of it's not just a button that
releases nuclear weapons there's a bunch
of people in between right right and if
some of those people think that they
have a chance of survival
that this is a personal thing against
the leader
what's their what is their rational
what is their rationale for pressing
that button down the line how terrifying
is this because the answer is a few
people but the answer is death right if
you're in that situation you your family
your kids is going to burn to ashes or
die in a radioactive wasteland yes so
why would you push that button if you
felt there was any chance of survival at
all that is one of the biggest [ __ ]
sources of anxiety for people is the
idea that we're living in this conflict
that we have zero control over that
might lead to a global thermonuclear war
at any moment in time the wrong buttons
might get pressed and the wrong people
might get mad at the wrong military
decisions might get made and someone
just tries to [ __ ]
do something wild
we didn't really think that that was a
possibility until this ukrainian
invasion yeah i think the ukraine
invasion opened up a lot of people's
eyes because there's so many people from
ukraine that have relatives in russia
and vice versa
it's it's not like you're
you you might be at war with your own
people like people that you are
literally related to yeah that's what's
crazy i have family on both sides it's
wild yeah the idea is wild and the idea
that the the country has such
extraordinary control over the narrative
of what the people know about and hear
about
it well 80 of russians get their news
from tv and the the message is very
consistent and very clear we're about to
be attacked
nato is about to
destroy us
uh ukraine's full of nazis and all of
this stuff uh
completely baseless
but
that if you feed people that line long
enough that's what they're going to
believe how do you think this plays out
uh
i think anyone who attempts to predict
this is bullshitting man no you can't
predict things like this right now the
situation is russia is inching forward
both sides are losing a lot
uh i think what
the russian strategy is to
to wait until winter that's what i'm
being told to hold out until winter and
by winter they think they can persuade
the germans to essentially sabotage the
western efforts to stop them i think
that's their plan
how that goes
how do we know we can't predict that
and in the meantime it also depends on
what's happening on the ground right it
depends on what russia is going to do it
depends on what the western
powers do in terms of providing weapons
and ammunition and all of that
so we've got no idea
at all it's so wild and when you hear
the government bragging about how much
money they're sending over to ukraine to
help fight the russians it's like maybe
shut the [ __ ] up for all time
remember that one you might want to keep
under your hat
uh yeah oh you mean in terms of talking
about it publicly i mean i'm joking but
i'm saying like the the idea that we're
we're essentially paying for this war so
are we at war or like well at what point
in time do you become at war with russia
you're not paying for this war you're
supporting a country that's defending
itself i agree but that's i'm not saying
they shouldn't do it what i'm saying i'm
not saying they should i'm just
i'm not saying i don't have an opinion
about it for american taxpayers to
decide that right it's not american
soldiers
but it is american money right so you're
funding the war and again i'm not saying
i'm against this yeah but i'm saying
at what point would someone who knows
we're funding that consider us at war
with them they already considered us at
war with them but i mean enough that an
attack would be warranted like that
someone would do something if the united
states is so vulnerable i mean if
someone just attacked our power grids
there's a lot of vulnerability in the
united states right yeah if they just
did that and shut the power down for six
months i mean how how effective would we
be at almost anything like the whole
world is vulnerable at this point in
time with nuclear weapons but but we're
we're all particularly vulnerable and if
there's some sort of an engagement going
on like that where we're funding
and maybe people believe we should maybe
we should i don't know
but this is what they're doing is
they're funding this war
they're helping ukraine fund this war
right at least
and i'm not saying this is a blow back
from not even concerned i'm just saying
that what would not just pull back from
russia blow back from any country where
we would do this at how much money do
you put in before they go oh you're at
war with us
i see what you're saying yeah i mean if
you think about all the different times
we've done this yeah all throughout
history and to aid armies and and fund
them and give them weapons at what point
in time would someone who opposes those
people feel like we're at war with them
yeah i see what you're saying so in
russia the narrative is that
we've been at war with the west this
entire time
the entire time yeah well this is a
defensive action because of nato because
we are quite this is the russian version
you understand i'm not saying i believe
this i'm saying that the the argument
not the perception of the russian people
the argument that is being made
is that we are uh you know it's siege
mentality right right and so that's what
people there think so from their
perspective they already feel that we're
a war
and have done from the beginning
now if you're talking about kinetic war
right then i think if the only way that
becomes an issue is if the united states
gets directly or nato gets directly
militarily involved
it's like you start shooting down
russian planes or shooting russian tanks
then then then then of cour well
but apart from that i don't see it
because you talk about vulnerability
america is the least vulnerable country
in the world
you're the world superpower
but even the world i'm not saying you're
not vulnerable oh of course yeah i know
i understand what you're saying yeah
i think um what's terrifying to all of
us is that we didn't expect this and we
don't know where it's going yeah you
know and that it's happening
it's it's it's happening to this place
that used to historically be connected
as the soviet union yeah it's it's
fascinating to me but here's the thing
if people are terrified
yeah people are terrified in the uk
because
we've bought into this idea that the
west has eliminated war you know with a
few pockets of things going on but we're
safe and we don't have to concern
ourselves with that about being having
another country you know being
aggressive and invading and whatever
else so we've bought into that and we
felt really safe so safe that we've
eliminated it from our minds and this
has been an incredibly sharp wake-up
call this has been a slap to the face
around the west
and it's what it's saying is
you ain't as safe as you think you are
and and the world never in the world
doesn't change there will always be war
have you ever read anything by thomas
sol
yes have you read a conflict of visions
no
he talks about most of what i've seen in
seoul just watched him speak yeah
brilliant brilliant um
he talks about two visions of the world
right the constrained what he calls the
constrained vision and the unconstrained
vision
and the constrained vision says that
human beings are flawed human beings
have certain predispositions human
beings aren't rational human beings
behave the way they behave and the best
way to understand how they are likely to
behave in the future is to look at how
they behave now and how they've always
behaved right right and the
unconstrained vision is essentially
progressivism
it's the belief that this can be changed
fundamentally right is the belief that
if you
um if you do enough social engineering
you're going to get to a position where
people are going to stop being the way
that they are and we're going to build
new people a new man
uh this is what people said in the
soviet union homoseveticus right a new
type of human being can be created
and
we view the world now through that
vision through the progressive vision
the idea that there would never be war
the idea that people would never want to
attack us the idea that you know when i
went to university to study politics the
the thing that was doing the rounds at
the time was they called it the golden
arches theory of international conflict
which was that no two countries with
mcdonald's had ever gone to war
right
it's hilarious yeah and the idea was
everyone's too fat no the idea was
they're corporately involved and they
would prevent this there's so much trade
going on yeah that it just doesn't make
sense for countries to attack each other
right right because and that
is a belief that human beings are
rational
right you believe that people will
always act in their own self-interest as
they understand them right but they
don't people act because they want
status people act because they want
power people act because they're scared
people act for all sorts of irrational
reasons that don't necessarily
correspond to the reality and i think we
also have to take into consideration
that when you're talking about russia
when you're talking about the population
they're not as exposed to information to
the free flow of information as we are
in america they there's a lot of people
that might have these notions in their
head based on what they've seen on
television they might buy it hook line
and sinker yeah and there might be good
people they're just duped well most
people in russia are good most people in
every country in every country have you
ever traveled to a country where most of
the people were [ __ ]
new york
new york is a bit like they're a little
they're a little celebratory in their
[ __ ] yeah they are they yeah they
call it a new york academy i'm from new
york